with increasing powers of H applied to the initial state. It looks like we can just make our Kryoff subspace by time
evolving our initial guess state. And that's almost true. The caveat is in
realizing the time evolution on a real quantum computer. Many of the terms in the Hamiltonian will not commute with
each other. So while some simple exponential operators like e to the negative i z correspond to simple
circuits general hamiltonians do not and since they contain non-commuting terms
we can't simply decompose the exponential into a product of simple ones the way we can with numbers. So
this is not trivial but this is a wellstudied process in quantum computing. We carry out time evolution
on quantum computers using a process called trotterization which in itself is a rich subject. But at a very high level
by breaking the time evolution into small steps say M steps we limit the effects of the non-commutativity of
terms. Let us call the krylov subspace of order r that we generated in the classical context using powers of h
directly the power kryov subspace kpr.
Now we generate a similar space using the unitary time evolution operator u given by the exponential of iht.
We'll refer to this as the unitary kryov space kur.
The power krylov subspace kpr that we use classically can't be generated directly on a quantum computer as h is
not a unitary operator. Using the unitary krylo subspace can be shown to give similar convergence
guarantees as the power kryov subspace.
Specifically, the ground state error converges efficiently as long as the initial state V has overlap with the
true ground state that is not exponentially vanishing and as long as there's a sufficient gap between igen
states. Here powers of u become different time steps. The kith power of u is stepping
forward by a time k * dt.
We can label the element of the subspace that is time evolved for a total time kdt as s sub k. We can project our
Hamiltonian H onto the unitary kryoff subspace kur. In other words, we
calculate each matrix element of h in the kur basis. We'll refer to this
projected matrix as h till day. The matrix elements of H till day are given by these expectation values which can be
estimated using the quantum computer.
Keep in mind that H can be written as a sum of poly operators on different cubits and that not all poly operators
can be measured simultaneously. We can sort the poly terms into groups of commuting terms and measure all of
those at once. But we may need many such groups to cover all the terms. So the number of distinct commuting groups into
which the terms can be partitioned ngcp becomes important. If we use a unitary krylo subspace of dimension r the
resulting matrix will have dimensions r * r. If r is much less than n then we've
made useful progress and typically r is much less than 100 meaning we can diagonalize this easily on a classical
computer. But recall that s n and s m will not generally be orthogonal. It is
sometimes possible to diagonalize a matrix in a non-orththogonal basis. But there are numerical and physical reasons
for first changing to an orthogonal basis. Hence we solve a generalized igen value problem using the gram matrix s.
The mn element of the gram matrix is given by the inner product of s m on cn.
Both the elements of H till day and S are calculated using a hatamart test.
The generalized igen value problem then becomes this.
As noted above, the dimension of the unitary krylo subspace R is exponentially smaller than our initial
matrix dimension N. So this value problem is simple to solve classically.
To recap, we start with a reference state, then evolve it for different periods of time to generate the unitary
krylov subspace. We project our Hamiltonian onto that subspace and we also estimate the overlaps of the
subspace vectors. Finally, we solve the lower dimensional generalized value problem classically. Let's compare what
determines computational costs of using the kryoff technique classically and quantum mechanically. We sketched this
already for the classical version and there are not perfect analoges between classical and quantum approaches for all steps. But this table collects some
scaling of different steps for consideration. Recall that Hamiltonians generally have terms that cannot be simultaneously measured because they do
not commute. We sort terms in the Hamiltonian into groups of commuting poly operators that can all be measured simultaneously and we may require many
such groups to account for all the terms that do not commute. To build up H till day on a quantum computer requires
separate measurements for each group of commuting poly strings in the Hamiltonian. And each of those require many shots. We must do this for R
squared different matrix elements corresponding to R squar combinations of different time evolution factors. There
are sometimes ways to reduce this. But in this rough treatment, the time required for this scales roughly like
the number of shots times the number of groups of commuting poly terms* r^ 2.
The elements of s must be estimated which scales like the number of shots
per cubed. We see that quantum kryof diagonalization may be useful in cases where the number of commuting poly
groupoups in the Hamiltonian is relatively small.
This scaling dependency suggests some applications where the kryoff method can be useful and others where it likely
will not be. Some Hamiltonians have high complexity when mapped to cubits involving many non-commuting polystrings
that cannot easily be partitioned into a few commuting groups.
This is often true of quantum chemistry problems. For example, this complexity presents two primary challenges for
near-term quantum computers. First, the estimation of each element of H till day becomes computationally expensive due to
the large number of terms. Second, the required troder circuits become prohibitively deep. Both of these points
will be less problematic when quantum computers reach fault tolerance, but they must be considered in the near term. Even systems with simpler mappings